hello everyone it is time
to catch up on the video game trailers
that came out of dc fandom i already
uploaded a video where i react to the
movie trailers and the batman movie
which i thought looked cool as hell now
we're gonna catch up on suicide squad
and gotham knights which are obviously
being developed by rocksteady and wb
montreal respectively um i think i'm a
little bit more excited about suicide
squad based on what i've seen i'm stoked
about quarterbacks and love that arc in
the comics um
that's super exciting but i didn't love
the look of the gameplay of gotham
knights previously where suicide squad
we kind of didn't get any so this time
around i'm kind of i'm going in with
different expectations obviously we've
seen these games before
um maybe i'll find gotham knights more
appealing i was expecting it to be more
arkham-esque than it looked uh but yeah
let's just let's just watch them shall
we let's do it
all of you are the worst of the worst of
the worst
still
you're good at what you do
i love kingston so much
oh every iteration of him i love
i will say in the harley quinn cartoon i
think he's my favorite
we're on punches
[Music]
you're perfect
but what is the video game
right this has one way ticket written
all over it
what the hell
i was going to say the first one looked
like the mimics from
do
price
dad
task force x
your new mission
is to kill the justice league
i mean it's an exciting challenge
so this is also a stroller trailer i
guess we're not gonna get game plan here
the idea of that is a boss fight
raise your hand if taking on the justice
league is the worst idea you've ever
heard
i can't design that
what did you think would happen you'd
crawl out of yourselves swoop in save
the day
which superheroes did you say you were
of course they all have to be
manipulated that's the only way that
they'd let us kill the heroes surely
right
oh
oh my
he's not gonna make it
there's so much boss fight potential is
the thing the penguin is in flight
repeat the penguin is in flight
that's actually pretty messed up
no
it very much did not get him a waller
waller blow up his head
that's pretty messed up
um
okay so didn't get a ton more from that
it looks fun yeah this whole thing just
has me thinking about the boss fight
potential and i do really like the way
that rock city's done all the boss
fights like um the killer croc one i
think was probably my favorite because
it felt very unique uh the scarecrow
ones are obviously incredible
and so if we get boss fights like that
with these heroes that we know really
well that could be very very very cool
um a cool trailer i was hoping for
gameplay
i'm not sure if they announced that they
want giving gameplay and so i was wrong
for that expectation i strongly agree
with angelo here saying seeing the
arkham sign in arkham prison was
nostalgic to the first arkham game 100
seems like people really like it they
like the tone yeah
yeah worried about how it'll actually
play but the chemistry between them is
flawless i don't know about flawless
but
uh i agree i think i think i like it i
think it it looks like fun it suits
suicide squad
i don't know if i would call it a game
of the year contender just yet without
seeing too much of the game but also
have faith in rocksteady so it looks
neat do you agree the penguin bit does
kind of feel like it was written by
james gunn himself
um
yeah didn't add a ton to
what i already thought but i'm satisfied
let's jump over to gotham knights which
we have seen a lot more of this is the
official court of al's story trailer
and i do love cordovals
batman
jim gordon
they thought they had a handle on this
city
they never did
you
don't stand a chance
it's very pretty
because they're always looks really
really good
i don't feel like gameplay looked quite
this good though
mine
yours
but no one talks about them
not a whispered word is said the court
of owls is a myth
is it both they're listening
i mean this is exciting
this is for sure all
very cinematic
[Music]
i can't not get excited by this
it's that's like
very reminiscent of the comics that
imagery if you really want to go down
this rabbit hole you need to know
there's no coming back from it
[Applause]
listen
i think i was going to be excited by
that
based on the premise absolutely no
matter what i was going to be stoked
about it and that is really cool like it
it looks awesome there's a lot of
potential for what they can do with like
the maze and everything um which rules
but yeah i wasn't super into gotham
knights when i first saw it just based
on the way the gameplay looks the the
multiplayer aspect um i think it had
damage meters if i remember correctly or
at least uh like numbers
um it looked a lot more like
i don't know destiny's it's a lazy
example but then i expected where you
know i was kind of hoping for gotham
knights to be more arkham
um it definitely seems like the suicide
squad is probably going to be slightly
more arkham
gotham knights is his own thing and i
respect that wb montreal is doing that
for sure it seems like a lot of work
went into it but yeah i'm just not
totally sold on the gameplay
which is certainly
a thing
this guy's been in both the comment
sections that i've read over
um certainly a thing that is important
but
oh that's an interesting one um scarier
than
scarecrow and arkham knight i hope so
if they make it scarier than scarecrow i
would be all about that actually that's
a good way to get me is make any game
scary and i'm gonna be like oh
interesting
so hey looked neat too um
would have liked to have seen one
gameplay from either of these
if they did drop gameplay trailers and i
totally missed them please let me know
and i would love to catch up on those um
just because yeah i've been a bit
preoccupied today i've said why in the
movie trailer reacts video but
yeah they're not too far away either
which is exciting um and i love me
some batman and i love the arkham game
so across the board start to get
more video games just in general it's a
huge win for everybody uh let me know
what you guys thought of all the dc
fandom stuff and please do tell me um so
you can help me catch up on what i
really need to check out what i might
have missed i would appreciate that but
otherwise that is it for me today
everyone i will see you guys next time
bye